hi guys I am just McComb I'm sad for
you're not serene
I am Seb Ford of GameSpot UK but in my
spare time I do like watching people
play horror streams because it's
hilarious and this particular mod was
one that I saw somebody playing on
YouTube and it looked downright
terrifying and I feel like you know
would be fun if I made set play that I
think that's a fad it's by a user called
unearthly brutal and you can grab it on
indie DB I think it's also on ModDB yeah
if you just search its an amnesia the
Dark Descent mod so if you just look up
when life no longer exists into the
nameless pain yes I it's much scarier
than the named pain so serene is in
Japan right now she's been on holidays
she'll be back in the office tomorrow
and back on this show next week cuz
Mouse is set to super sensitive don't
look left
nobody needs to look left oh yeah Oh up
there oh yeah oh yeah he see me oh my
god what the balls is that not right up
to where he is yes look at that
okay well that's creepy as [ __ ]
oh but could not be running any faster
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] died what yeah oh oh yeah yeah
sanity's like bask in this glorious
sunlight probably get killed in this
glorious sunlight oh yeah good okay okay
that's one down okay done oh for God's
sake it's a heavy ass to war thank you
Hey
Oh run away you should have got down you
should get down god [ __ ] ass crack
what's it what's your technique is the
corner technique isn't it
Redbook and Bronk seriously [ __ ] move
real slow [ __ ] Christ who the [ __ ]
off Jesus oh Christ don't look at it
let's run away no ideal not ideal oh I'm
so not going here you can't hide in it
like that your person what how does this
help you this one doesn't have a door
[ __ ] not every part of me is thinking
they're going through the mist is smart
everything's on fire
well oh my god huh run all the way all
the way we go in the other way
double back double back
oh he's run that way that means run that
means it's him
oh [ __ ] Oh the music's going you're just
like that's the water that we're gonna
go up now yep oh I don't know what to do
take that go straight right straight
this is this is the way I remember Falls
Bulls balls oh my god good posture you
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah you're a genius
run [ __ ] keep running damn it
death awaits sucks [ __ ]
monster fill the wall I think you're
gonna get killed in less than five
minutes put it on the clock guys less
than five minutes okay well a thing
happened [ __ ] Oh wrong loser buys pizza
that seems fair come on five minutes are
ya gonna shut up
we don't need to read it hold the
crucifix oh there's like all this stuff
here if I drop this for even a second
there's only one thing Oh
there's candles and also a useful crap I
think so yeah is that meant to just
tempt me probably a real monster
really
right step jump oh that was close
I just got left he's in there fishes
like yes I already died no oh my god
he's everywhere
you must be around the corner I don't
want to go I don't want to go I don't
want to go old areas sure you gotta move
you're not on the box you know that
right okay well shakes
Olmert you gotta go he's gonna keep
hitting you Oh didn't get me from this
girl back then what a monster has matter
age Oh take your clothes off why did we
take our clothes off like all of a
sudden what's up naked person no a
friend hey it could be a scary song out
all right
that was super I don't even know I want
to say like eight different words there
there it's okay the naked man is gone
oopsies sorry sorry friend oh he's up oh
[ __ ]
uh um he's gonna be mad he's gonna be
mad oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I call me I call me I Jimmy okay
crappy bugga bugga bugga
come wow that was some epic picking up
of the bodies there's another future
thing that's gonna hate me hate the key
see I told you Mikey now she's looking
like it run [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] someone's coming keep going yeah
go that way maybe this would be easier
if we had half a brain but I think maybe
he literally walked in the room and
looked straight at the photos and
straight at the wood and we didn't get
it not even a clue whoa nope just carry
on oh good we alright well we've done it
that was another episode of house of
horrors way every single week and by me
I mean we I mean me and zareen know I
mean this game is made your head melt in
the meantime leave us your comments and
thoughts on YouTube and GameSpot and
your suggestions for games mm-hmm
anything you like use our HOH live
hashtag on Twitter and that's pretty
much the ball game so until then we'll
catch you guys again soon and thanks for
joining me I'm so sorry guys I'm so
sorry yeah we do right bye bye
you